[Music]
ditto Pattaya
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
how could you let Balthasar brats just
get away you're fired
he really did to snuggle with I miss
what are you doing since you don't have
a job I just wanted to help
ah excuse me hey could you oh of course
now as I was saying I good my seriously
Wow I really must have a word with you
on behalf of your twin brother drew why
twin brother hey brother
I can't wait to meet my brother
[Music]
doesn't love this guy
look at him Elvis hair would make you
better look at this face why so mad you
must see the beautiful wife oh sweet
talker this place is amazing it's nice
like gasps you're I'm not really into
things basic groove you losing blood
koukin boobs you ready to continue the
family tradition you and me no I left
that life behind me just one mmm
[Music]
I'm going in
[Music]
haha okay
this does not mean that we are going
back from being valence
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]